our flight has gone down this is
an emergency and survived together
die alone we're getting off this island
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
oh is he dangerous what did he do homicide 15
years ago I don't want to scare the rest of
the passengers I'm afraid you're stuck with this
captain get them on board let's have a good flight
right through the top of the storm us to keep
everybody in their seats no exceptions all right
we are dark
then we're done somewhere
in the Jolo Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there anymore
the clock is ticking every minute matters we
can count those minutes in lives lost or saved
we don't know who it is listen carefully this
is an emergency I'm captain Brody Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England country
I gotta go after them my
passengers my responsibility
I'm gonna need your help you're gonna need
this perform a militarism you can see that
so why'd they lock you up
no one cares what really happened they say
redemption can be found in the most unusual places
if you do this you'll probably never
see your family again what about
their families I have a daughter and I
have every intention of making a home
they're going to come at us
with everything they've got
we're getting off this island